hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to seven days to die with
my good buddy Wade how you doing guys
hey doing today Wade I'm going are you
oh yeah this is not good already
yeah why are you yelling at me for Wade
I'm just trying to say hi you're getting
a net it buddy good right away okay okay
so anyway we're back with 782 died we
didn't really intend to play much more
of this because we felt like we played
it out but there was a new alpha that
was released in it contains a new biome
and a lot of different systems in it so
are you headed towards a biome right now
I don't know you just run it in a random
direction without even knowing yeah
we're going to the by we're to go
through the farm then we'll go up uh
we'll go to the left which is north is
that the farm Coronado Coronado yes
Coronado that is the farm okay anyway
far monado we're going to the snow biome
to see what's new there Riley is gonna
play a couple more episodes of it but
also because it was boring and whatever
it was playing normally we got it set on
the hardest difficulty I kept explaining
this to wait we're gonna be playing on
the hardest difficulty that means
there's gonna be more zombies and
they're gonna be deadlier and there's
gonna be less supplies because just what
we need with our perfect no-nobody's the
guys cuz we're dumb no because we're on
duh I don't know what were you looking
for Dan we're on the hardest difficulty
I've been said that oh yeah I wanted you
to say it oh why would I say it again
because it's a back and forth Oh
the hardest difficulty well yeah you're
just making fun of it now I was being
serious about this and you're just
taking it in a different direction
anyway we need to get luckily we didn't
spawn at the very bottom of the map yeah
that would be so tragic had we done that
yeah it would have been totally
illogical to try to run all the way up
there and then denial once we got close
and then die and then respawn back all
the way at the bottom southwest corner
of the map when the snow biome is
in the northeast corner and then get
angry at each other we started dear bye
yeah so lucky anyway can we just say
that we have never played this game and
had it go smoothly from the beginning we
have never ever played this game and
have it go smoothly yeah typically it's
not just a spawning issue though
yeah well I'm Ann and I have to say it's
probably not our fault
either you know or it's not like the
game's fault we just get unlimited corn
here pretty much with this is amazing
yeah why is this here why is this still
here a limited corn yeah in these zombie
apocalypse of radioactive nothingness
there's just totally at the peak of
harvest season corn sitting right here
makes total sense yeah I understand what
your issue is with this why did we even
build a potato farm on a roof in a
wasteland when we could just come here
because actually if zombies run through
this it like destroys the corn I don't
care
there's enough to last forever is there
yes what if it goes bad or spoils before
we can eat it does it how does it do
that
Oh exactly stop trying to mess with me
trying to mess with me man I know your
tricks I know how much of douche you be
how much I need a gun oh okay well then
you don't need a gun just yet we're
getting to the north
we gotta keep moving get are you you're
still in the farm get out I'm going
we're moving I see you yeah keep moving
can you catch him - he's cooler than
seeds what am I gonna do with this
that's good enough when we're surviving
in the frozen north
oh we're fighting frozen monsters how
about you stop complaining for - so into
the city or do we not have time cuz one
o'clock in the afternoon we should just
go straight to the snow biome and find a
place there okay huddle up in a shack
take off our clothes everybody it is for
your nose well that's not the direction
I was gonna take it in but yeah that's
probably better for everyone watching if
we turn it up slap dem hos nah also not
the direction I was going I didn't think
that there would be hoes waiting for us
in the frozen north
Pinocchio is knows his it grows what his
nose grows okay I don't know where
direction you were going I've tried all
the different ones that I could think of
you just keep going in a more disturbing
direction then again that's how most of
your conversations go by the way I'm
taking all the things in front of you so
there's gonna be nothing left for you
yeah what does this sign mean it means
there's a national forest here boom oh
dear
boom [ __ ] I missed it Han I'm gonna get
it stop running away fire I'm gonna
shoot you boom got it collect its meats
how it doesn't have a oh there it is
okay got it
get out of there got it move oh you're
winning
where are you ahead of me now cuz I had
one I was gonna wait for you okay
alright fine then jeez
dick I'll go to pistol yeah I can't
believe I have to survive in this place
with you I can't believe I don't have
anything that I can't believe yeah
that's right yeah yes what I thought
good sir but rather be here with Bob
geez Wow you don't need to be so
melodramatic about it okay yay everybody
watching snow exciting this amazing who
would even sounds calm what a vacation
we're taking from our relationship Wade
I know did you get a sitter for our baby
baby uh yeah I got a cannibal to watch
it oh good I was all worried you would
get a zombie wait a minute
what cannibal no that's our baby baby
baby oh hi nicknamed it baby I'm not
paying for diapers anymore I'm done
oh that's so sad didn't you make a joke
last night at iHelp about something
about diapers I remember that very
distinctly cuz it was so bad it was just
like you have bad joke not everyone
knows me and Wade we go get dinner all
the time and we embarrass her everyone
around us cuz we're in the middle of
restaurant making you know these jokes
this is what we do online but in a
restaurant so he made some horrible
horrible joke because he caught
not stop making puns cuz for some reason
he thinks that puns are like the most
glorious of all humor but I can't say
what was your booze your diaper joke I
don't remember it do you remember it
no I'm asking you to say it I would say
if I remembered one okay well that was
the most anti-climactic body that's
going with it I was just saying like I
was playing you up as if you could use
all the time without knowing what I'm
saying whatever
alright fine then okay so we're here did
we have a plan then when we get here
what wait there's a building nearest
let's go to it which building there's a
lot of buildings over here all the one
over there can I say you run really
funny Oh run around me real quick no
come back just run in a circle around me
I don't know who you are right here Oh
run for me baby run for me you're not
running okay what is I look silly
anymore
you can't just ruin it I keep giving you
a chance
you keep brewing it Hey look silly
before you did it different now your
ass'll I can't hold shift mine's
penguins no did you leave me in here to
do this what land mines I'm collecting
them I'm gonna kill you you you you led
me astray here oh this seems like a
decent barrier to hold off these zombies
oh I just collected all of our barrier
no you didn't oh the land mines oh okay
this is actually good Oh what I got I
got good weapons okay good I couldn't
tell us at first you with a sniper rifle
or a rocket launcher I couldn't tell if
that was you're all zombies or oh I
found something that was my own where'd
you find whatever you were having this
tower oh okay then I guess I'm out
barbed wire hurts mine articles hey we
could have a meeting here if we could
get our employees to gather around we
could have a meeting cuz I'm gonna rip
the meat off your body
hahaha why wait what no what huh you
know I just realized that there's really
no good place to actually hold off here
that tower looks nice
oh yeah
it does there's nothing out yeah yeah
yeah there's nothing else here so you
just have a machine gun in a rocket
launcher right uh it's not for rifle and
rocket launcher I've also got a pistol I
got a shotgun Oh Jimoh kind of shotgun
is it is it sold off no it's a bumpy
here sawed off bumpy you got one too and
there's some more ammo for it
oh wait which one's better a pumpy or a
sawed-off pump II uh I don't know guess
a solid office better close range of
pumps better for medium range screw it
I'm going with the pump II that's good
shove do we need to gather anything cuz
no it weighted some 524 right now I'm
gonna what's near I mean there's another
building we could try to make it two
no there's no time we got a hold off
here give me water this is our final
stand I'm almost a food oh no wait I got
the UH the deer meat mm where did you
gather corn yeah corn we have plenty no
water though yeah I don't honey water
right if I gathered some blueberries
blueberries give a little wait there's a
lake just on the south of us I'm gonna
run for it do you have glasses no but
I'm gonna dip in and open my mouth and
hope for the best
alright that's a lot of what she said
OOP OOP let's hope I don't blow myself
up you don't think that the lake would
be booby-trapped
sploosh drinking it up gosh so tasty did
you drink it yeah maybe know the answer
to that question was no but I got empty
jars wait I might ah horrible words Kyle
yeah I got five empty jars or five
bottles of water oh I'm gonna come jump
in the water with you
please do this is my ideal she lives in
there what nothing huh
don't forget me what are you doing I'm
just taking off my pants for a moment
okay yeah please do
yeah I'm just over here enjoying the
show huh don't ask me why really creepy
zombie just gather around and watch this
play in the water well that's what
hundreds of
the people on the internet are doing
doesn't that doesn't that actually like
blow your mind
hundreds of thousands of people and it's
not an exaggeration yeah that is weird
hundreds of thousands okay I'm I'm
replacing the land mines again so we
don't get dead defied okay all right
this is where we make our final stand
little I don't then wasted
it's the final stand I don't think
that's why is this corn not really doing
much for me
oh no I'm placing laying mines why there
all right fine huddle up in our Tower
okay are you gonna give me the rock
what's this without the deer disturber
landmine still alive
it's got deer no no dear no you stupid
deer look at this stupid dumbass deer
and all its dumbass ways really deer you
this cuz I think this will be comical
what it's in the box
what whoa
final worst thing I've ever done you
want to try to blow up that deer what I
mean look sure why not no it's too far
away I might miss I got a sniper rifle
I've only got like 13 bullets though
really oh man this would be interesting
to see once the zombies start spawning
but we don't have any like torches or
anything to make like a perimeter so
they don't spawn inside us what did you
assume din on its butt I hit the trees
you're lucky oh my god I was zoomed in
on that that was it yeah baby all right
hello it told you you're very pretty I I
was uh oh you'd like it
Oh stare at this while I undulate Oh
what I moved you stop staring at it
yeah I did did you not like my
undulation no okay we can leave your
Punja Latian somewhere else I'll take
your Punja Latian how do I make a go
like that just fire I'll know
landmine black glasses Wow I fell I fell
off it's okay I'm gonna play some
torches down here so that not everything
will try to spawn right and underneath
us all those other gear go for the land
boy no do you know please don't do it
no it wouldn't be hilarious no don't
don't run shot one kill
hey is that a line from something are
you
is it a slime for slime is it a slide Oh
have you been looking at my shrine the
houses of a schlong if it's not let's
make it please dear God because that is
hilarious
slide assigned my schlong if you know
what I mean
everyone had comments start using that
when you strong to me my water park Ivan
fire Slav in your slide that is a God
rabbit the poor bunny he got blown to
smithereens how these mines lasted this
long
the animals have destroyed them in the
five minutes we've been here I don't
know but I'm gonna put a tree trunk to
block people from climbing up this lad
dog okay ah where was that one back here
goddamn rabbits not a signal song you've
been killed
oh I see the body of that look you want
to go get the tasty tasty meat oil
blotting you like my slip tips do you
hear something like a little staticky
kinda yeah what is that it's like a
radio or something I didn't even know
that radios were in this game I don't
think they are but I hear this night is
gonna get weird what is that now it
sounds like someone's chewing on meat oh
this is getting scary actually
hell is going on here did you just zip
something I moved some ammo to my oh yes
I slipped up my sling so you can yeah
that's awkward
thank you what did you think we were
gonna do here don't answer for warmth
ha ha ha god I'm gonna zip down my pants
and start undulating what'd you do to my
sling with your slung is up to you let's
go sit with Timmy over his ship oh no
nothing no nothing Timmy doesn't approve
maybe I shouldn't be holding the rocket
launcher while I pointed things cuz I've
been known to miss click with this mouse
all the time that would be so bad our
only possible place of being safe here
yeah all right it's officially nighttime
time to show three quiet out there when
a zombies gonna show up bring it on
maybe they won't is that a thing that
can happen I don't think so but you know
it's pretty quiet so far it's already uh
getting late what is it 10:30 at night
well then it's probably a good time to
just give this episode of clothes on
this peaceful note all right yeah and
then who knows what else could happen
yeah certain things could go into other
things
no slinging mush long and what you have
a sling now who's who has a sling among
the two of us let's be very clear
ma tell I don't think Timmy's you leave
Timmy out of this you leave our baby
baby out of this he's so precious whoa
rebus don't worry
all right we're gonna cut it here and
then see what happens at night so stick
around if you want to know anyway thank
you all so much for watching thank you
Wade for joining me on this misadventure
rowdiness oh no no
No